>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Applause ]
>> David S. Mao: My name is David
Mao and I have the privilege
and honor of serving as the
Acting Librarian of Congress.
Welcome to the closing lecture
of the Poet Laureate Consultant
in Poetry at the Library
of Congress.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
In June of last year, the
13th Librarian of Congress,
James H. Billington,
appointed Juan Felipe Herrera
as the 21st Poet Laureate.
We are very grateful that Dr.
Billington, now the Librarian
of Congress Emeritus,
and Mrs. Billington,
are here with us this evening.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
During Dr. Billington's
tenure as Librarian
of Congress he appointed
19 Poets Laureate, so, yes,
please join me again in thanking him
for his [applause] steadfast support
of not only this program here
at the Library of Congress --
[ Applause ]
-- but also his steadfast
support for this art form.
At the start of Mr. Herrera's term,
he launched La Casa de Colores,
and I apologize, I
don't speak Spanish.
It's an online project that
allows everyone the opportunity
to contribute to his epic
crowdsourced poem, "La Familia."
Critics have said "La Familia"
spans languages, topics, structures,
tones, and is a stream of
consciousness that echoes the vast
yet connected fears and
joys of people in America.
And I want to encourage all
of you to participate in this.
You can still participate.
Come to our website, loc.gov, and
just simply search for Poetry,
and then you, too, can be
a part of this epic poem.
Now such an ambitious project
is really rare for laureates
as they usually take, mm,
about six months just to figure
out what they want to
do in the position.
But I think it surely came as
no surprise to those of you
that are familiar with
Mr. Herrera's tenure
as California's State Poet Laureate.
But this is really only half of Mr.
Herrera's power in the position.
The other half comes from
his own award-winning work.
And now, as Dr. Billington said
last year, "Mr. Herrera's poems,"
and I quote, "engage in a
serious sense of play in language
and in image that gives
them enduring power.
I see how they champion voices,
traditions, and histories,
as well as a cultural
perspective which is a vital part
of our larger American identity."
Following the announcement
of Mr. Herrera's selection,
a noted critic wrote in the
Los Angeles Review of Books ,
"As a poet who makes
impassioned connections
from his Chicano subjectivity to
his role as Citizen of the Americas
to his participation
as a global citizen,
Herrera has written an exceptional
body of work, a true testament
to his unwavering convictions and
respect for the power of language.
He's a consummate artist
and activist
who will bring a different energy
and perspective to his duties
as Poet Laureate of
the United States."
And truly he has done
that over the last year.
[ Applause ]
All of this energy was evident
in Mr. Herrera's opening reading
at the Library last September.
And I think maybe many of
you were here for that.
That was an event that the
Washington Post said, and I quote,
"was infused with humility
and graciousness."
Well, I think tonight's event
titled "Pioneers of Flowers
and Song" will undoubtedly
extend that spirit
as our Laureate celebrates poets
important to his own development
and invites to very, very
special guests to join him
and celebrate the future.
And I think you're going to be
really surprised and pleased
with what he has in store
for us this evening.
This even is presented in
partnership with Split This Rock
and serves as the opening event
for the Split This Rock Festival.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
So a special thanks to
Split This Rock Co-Founder
and Executive Director,
Sarah Browning,
for her help in promoting
Juan Felipe Herrera --
[ Applause and Cheering ]
-- Herrera's laureateship.
And I might add, thank
you for also providing
for sign language interpretation.
It's very important for
this program this evening.
[ Applause ]
Now I want to also
take this opportunity
to make a very important
announcement.
This may be Herrera's
final event of his term,
but it's not his last
as Poet Laureate.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
As Acting Librarian of
Congress, I'm very pleased to say
that I've renewed Juan
Felipe Herrera
as the 21st Poet Laureate Consultant
in Poetry for a second term.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
And if you've been amazed with
all the work that he's done just
in this first term, I can only
imagine what he will accomplish
in the second year.
So stay tuned for things to come.
Please join me in welcoming
him to our stage.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Thank you.
Thank you, David.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
It's a great please.
Muchas gracias.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, David.
Thanks, everyone.
What a great joy.
What a great joy this is.
And I want to thank Dr. James
Billington who gave me a call
from the very beginning,
and our great staff --
Rob Casper and Anya
Creightney and Matt Blakely,
and the entire Library of Congress.
How beautiful it is to be
here, how beautiful the Library
of Congress is, how fabulous
are the materials and archives
and manuscripts and the
paintings and the prints
and Cervantes' first book
which is around this big.
However, you can make it
this big once you read it,
and much bigger than
the world perhaps.
I've met so many good people --
the division chiefs, the librarians
at large, and coming through the
front door, and coming up here,
and the beautiful receptions that
we have, and friends that appear
out of nowhere that I love
that have come to be with us,
and the great partnerships,
the great partnerships.
It really is about being a
community and about being a family,
a family with the voices
in the Library,
a family with the librarians,
a family with the beautiful
staff that put me together.
They go, "Okay, Juan
Felipe, where's your head.
Put it on.
And you got it together and
your feet, where are they?
Let's bring over the feet.
Okay. Put them back together.
Okay. Stand him upright.
Okay, okay.
Now push him out.
Push him out [laughter]."
And so that's what
they've been doing today.
I really appreciate it, and to be
here in Washington, D.C., you know,
representing everyone at the
Library of Congress and going
to so many places across the nation,
and meeting children and familias,
families that bring their children
to see me at the presentations,
and they say to their children, they
say, "This is Juan Felipe Herrera.
He's a Poet Laureate
of the United States.
I want you to say hi, okay?"
And then we say hi and hi, and
just that is -- that just --
that's is what we're
all about, right?
That's what we're all about.
We say hi and then we can read
and then we can talk about books.
But first we have to say hello and
meet each other and be together.
And then I meet the students
that have just graduated
and they're becoming teachers.
This was in Nevada,
Nevada State College.
I'm going to be a teacher.
I just got my certificate.
I go, great, fabulous.
And I'm so excited.
I go, excellent, that's
what it's all about.
So we do that, too.
And then writers that come and see
me at the event after the reading
and they go, oh, I
just -- I'm a poet.
I go, great.
And I have some poems.
I go, fabulous.
And can I show them to you?
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
And I really say okay.
I really do.
And we have a little mini workshop,
we have a little mini workshop
right there in-between everything,
there's a mini workshop.
And that's beautiful.
That's beautiful.
We also do little mini workshops
as we move along throughout
the nation and meeting people.
And children that raise their
hands and have a question for you.
And I go, by all means.
And then they have big questions,
they have giant questions
that fill up the whole space.
And I bring them up to the
stage and I go, can you repeat
that for the entire
audience of 700 people?
Okay? And then they
present their question.
And then the rest of the people that
come from the city and from beyond,
they listen to a new voice asking
big questions about literature
and how they want to write.
And this continues.
And I met, I did meet
two amazing writers,
11-year-old Sarita Sol Gonzalez, who
we're going to present at the end
of the program, and I did meet
Elena Medina also, 12-years-old.
They're going to present
at the end of the program,
and they're our Laureate
Chicas [laughter].
They're our Laureate Chicas.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
And that's kind of a little
bit of what's been happening
as I travel across the nation.
And pure joy, pure joy, pure
joy, 750 people, pure joy.
They drive for hours to come
and they drive through snow
in Milwaukee to be at the reading.
And in East L.A. they drive
from East L.A. They come
to the L.A. presentation at Cal
State Los Angeles and on and on.
So it's great.
This is a beautiful thing you're
all doing, we're all doing together,
and what the Library's all about.
So let's give a beautiful,
heartfelt,
big applause for everything,
for everyone here and beyond.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
Oh, yes. You know, tonight I want
to present you with the Pioneers
of Flower and Song,
Pioneers of [foreign word],
the Pioneers of [foreign words],
which are the Aztec Nahuatl terms
for poetry which translate
into flower and song.
So we were in Aztec times, and
still we have many Nahuatl speakers.
We would say [foreign words].
And they would say oh,
yeah, poetry, poetry.
And our pioneers were
very interested in poetry.
That is, the Latinos
and Latinas here
in the United States
during the last 50 years.
Something happened.
And we began to think about
our ancestors, and my friends
and my cadre and those that I
grew up with as a poet in cafes
and rallies and in the
streets of San Francisco
and San Diego in California.
And we kind of -- poetry
was like clay.
We found it and we grabbed it.
It was reddish, it was hot,
and we wanted to shape it,
and to do that many a time.
We had to go back to
the books and find some
of our roots and explore them.
And from there gain life and
present them to the world.
It was a big effort.
It was a very ambitious effort.
But we didn't think
about it like that.
I want you to see them this evening.
They were my mentors in
many ways, and a good number
of them have passed
away at a young age.
And I want to read you some of the
work as we move through the story
of who they were and what they did,
and some of their contributions.
"Pioneers of Flower and Song."
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Flower and song poetry.
This is Francisco Alarcon's
poem, who passed away a couple
of months ago in February.
A great poet who took on the
task of learning Nahuatl,
the language of the
Mashika, of the Aztecs.
And he writes this poem called "In
Flower and Song, [foreign words]."
Every tree, a brother.
Every hill, a pyramid, a holy spot.
Every valley, a poem
[foreign words], flower.
[Foreign words], song.
Flower and song.
Every cloud, a prayer.
Every raindrop, a miracle.
Everybody, a seashore, a
memory at once lost and found.
We all together fireflies in the
night, dreaming up the cosmos.
And I think --
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much for Francisco
and his legacy who worked so hard,
was a great teacher, great
writer for children, great poet,
never thought about
being acknowledged.
And it's an amazing, pioneering,
groundbreaking projects
that we still need to follow up
on, in particular the translation
of Aztec materials and his
spreading the word of that beauty
and that type of material,
and reinterpreting those
materials in his own way as well.
And perhaps that dreaming up
the cosmos required going back
to the glyphs and ancient walls
buried somewhere in Central America,
maybe in El Peten, Guatemala.
In this case, dug up by Heather
Hurst that I met on the road
who painted these glyphs and went
to Guatemala and crawled into a cave
that was dark and abandoned
and busted.
And she was curious.
She touched those walls
and she scratched
that mud and she carved it out.
And what did she find?
She found these murals that told
stories way earlier than the ones
that we had known about
in Bonampak in Chiapas.
I visited those murals back in 1970,
and yet they go further
back in time.
So these are the dreams,
these are the dreams.
This is a merit ceremony.
This is the brilliance
and bursting rays of corn.
And that's what we looked at.
That's what my friends looked at.
That's what these early poets were
interested in in the late '60s,
early '70s, through the '80s.
And with Francisco, all the way
through the '90s to the present.
But it wasn't easy because we had
this thing called the conquest.
We had to deal with that.
And it was a complex project.
Are we European, are we
Spanish, are we Indian,
are we Mexican, are we American?
And that's been an ongoing debate.
And not only a debate
but a soul-searching
voyage, a beautiful one also.
And perhaps this is -- this is one
of the texts that was very moving
when we began this
project in the late '60s.
A poem by [foreign words],
the elders of the Aztecs.
Everything was destroyed.
Millions of the peoples had died,
the Aztecs, given the encounter
with the Spanish, the
tragic invasion.
And this was recorded by Miguel
Leon-Portilla who was here recently
to receive the -- kind of like a
lifetime award, a living legend.
And that [foreign words], the
elder Aztecs are already --
have lost everything.
They represent the Mashika,
the Aztec Nation destroyed.
And they're standing
before the friars
who represent the new
way, the new knowledge.
And they say, "And
now what can we say?
What should we direct
toward your ears?
Are we even something?
We're just plain, vulgar people.
Through our translator we respond.
Between our breath and the word
of our lord of the near and far.
For him we risk everything.
This is why we're in danger.
Perhaps to our perdition,
perhaps to our destruction,
is where we will be taken.
But where should we go?
We are finite.
We are mortals.
Let us die in peace.
Let us vanish.
All of our deities have died.
Let your hearts and flesh
be calmed here, sirs.
We will break a little, bit by bit.
We'll open the secret,
the ark of our lord."
So spoke the Aztec, noble, nobles,
teachers that were now captured.
"You say that we don't know about
the lord of that which is near
and far, him who reigns over
the heavens and the earth.
You said that our goals were
not real, a new word this is
for us, that which you speak.
Because of it we're disturbed.
Because of it we are burdened,
because our ancestors,
those who have lived on this
earth never spoke this way.
They taught us their way of life.
They rendered real
tribute to their gods.
They taught us all of their
traditions and the way
in which they would honor their
gods like this before them.
We bring the earth to our
mouth, we bring the earth.
For them we bleed.
We made good on our promise,
burned the [foreign word],
and brought our offerings
for sacrifice.
This was a long time ago.
It was their [foreign word]
and [foreign word] in
the ancient cities --
-- until now.
Will we destroy the ancient laws
of life, those of the Chichimekas
and the Toltecas, the Alcohuas,
the ancient peoples, the Tepanecas?
We know to whom we owe our
life, to whom we owe our birth.
This is what we respond, what we
reply to your breath, to your word.
Oh, dear sirs."
So that translation by Miguel --
[ Applause ]
-- that translation by Miguel
Leon-Portilla, the great scholar
of Nahuatl thought and culture,
with his great book, Aztec Thought
and Culture , that came out in the
'60s, which was a right time for us
as young poets and searchers and
seekers of our writing and culture
and identity at that
time, the Civil Rights,
that new democracy,
was perfect, that book.
And that poem that I just read by
the [foreign word], the elders,
the speakers, the keepers of the
word that spoke to in response
to the friars was a page in a poem
that we literally memorized
and thought about.
So this is the way it was with
this generation that I'm speaking
of that we're paying
tribute to tonight.
And we shall see them.
And there's also the --
here we have in the Library,
we have the codex,
the Huexotzinco Codex.
And it's a little later, it's a few
years beyond 19 -- after 1915 24.
And it shows the, kind of a
tribute, codex of tribute,
of what has to be paid in
what amounts to the ruler.
In this case it's a colonist.
Things have changed.
And they respond, they
want to respond,
and they want to say
you're being unfair.
We have paid quite a bit.
We have worked hard, and
we don't think it's right,
and we're going to sue you.
The suit, suing people,
was possible now.
So the suit went forward.
I'm speaking about the social
response, how we all can respond,
and how we all have responded.
And I think the work that we have
here in the Library are responses
to reality, responses
to our visions,
responses to our creativity
in our hearts.
I'm going to move on to kind
of a more personal story,
the story of my father who comes
much later to the United States.
And he arrives in the late 1800s.
My father was born in 1882.
And this is him standing
up in Denver, Colorado.
He used to say, "Juanito,
it was so cold [laughter]."
I was 14. "I had jumped a train from
Chihuahua, from a little ranchito.
And when I got to Denver" --
remember, I was only 14 --
"and when I got to Denver
I jumped off the train.
It was so cold [laughter] that I
spit [spitting sound] and it turned
to little cubes of ice, Juanito."
[ Laughter ]
And my mother used
photographs to tell me stories.
This is one of the photographs
that she used in her album,
one of those Kress
or Woolworths albums.
That was the '50s.
And she'd show me the photograph
and she'd say, "This is your father,
Juan, and he's in Denver.
And this is 1904.
And this is his friend,
Jose Barrera.
And you see how he writes on
the sides of the photograph?"
"Yes, mama."
"And he writes, and you know he
learned how to speak English.
Guess how he learned."
How, mama?"
"He learned English by buying
a word for a penny, each word,
in English, for a penny."
A penny? A penny?"
"Si, Juanito."
So that's how my father learned how
to speak English, by buying words
for a penny when he worked very
hard as a cowboy, as a ranch hand,
in Wyoming and up north in Denver,
Colorado, also, and his friend.
And he liked to write and he liked
to read and he worked very hard
and he invented everything.
It was -- shoes fell apart,
he picked up pieces of leather
and hammered new leather on that
shoe and he could walk really cool.
And if we didn't have a house, he
found some wood and built it on top
of a beat-up old car, and my mother
would say, "What are you doing?"
He said, "See that
thing right there?"
"What?" "That beat-up old car."
"Yeah. Why?"
"I'm going to build a house."
"On that?"
"Yes." "Why?"
"Because we're going
to travel [laughter]."
"Where?" "We're going
to go to Ramona."
"Why?" "Because they have the
best water in the whole world."
"Like Don Quixote [laughter]?"
That was my father.
My mother came to Juarez
after the Mexican Revolution.
And it was a small
town and who knows?
You know, she came from the
poorest barrio in Mexico,
at Tepito, in -- around 1918.
And the Revolution had
rumbled everything up,
changed everything up, energized
everybody, everybody wanted to move
and go places, things
were falling apart,
and things were being recreated
like a living poem
earthquake had hit Mexico.
So she came up north with my
grandmother, Juanita, and my aunt,
Aurelia, to Juarez, to follow
the dream and follow my uncles,
Vicente [foreign words] and [foreign
word] and Roberto, to El Paso,
Texas, El Paso, Texas, to la
frontera, to the new experience
of the new life right after
Poncho Villa had passed
through there, actually.
And that was a good
example, you know.
Just get going and hop on a horse.
In this case, my mother and
grandmother hopped on a train.
Anthony Quinn had already
been there, by the way.
Anthony Quinn left Mexico
City with his mom around 1912
and hit Juarez also,
which is interesting.
Poncho Villa, Anthony
Quinn, and my mom.
[ Laughter ]
So I feel kind of good
about that, you know?
I feel really good.
It's a really interesting mix.
It's a really good blend.
And my mother, you know,
was spunky, you know.
My mother was spunky and
she wanted to be a dancer.
She always did rhymes and poetry
while we were having dinner
or tortillas.
And in the middle of
everything she would say --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
It was at 5:00 in the afternoon.
She would quote some, you
know, really deep poem.
It was 5:00 in the afternoon.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And then she would sit down.
Can you pass that tortilla, Juanito?
[ Laughter ]
She was very dramatic.
My mom was totally dramatic.
Everything was like drama.
Nothing was, you know,
even, even like that.
It was dramatic.
And she wanted to be a
dancer and singer and --
but, you know, the rules
that were very strict.
So she was kind of kept back from
following her dream as a actress
and as a singer and a dancer.
And, of course, those
theaters were speak theaters
and burlesque theaters and my
grandmother had a cobalt iron hand
and kept her back, but
didn't keep her dream back.
And she gave me her dream.
And that's how I started at home.
And that dream was also picked up
by the women of Juarez, very young,
16-year-old that I have
spoken to, who are in their --
one of them is still living --
she's around 99 and Cuka Aguirre
and with her sister Cuka --
Ava Aguirre and their
cousin, Elvira Macias.
And they formed a group
called [foreign words].
And it was great to
meet them in El Paso.
I went to El Paso.
We found each other in the Web
because I had spoken about --
at the radio theater of the 30's
that my uncle belonged
to [foreign words] XCJ.
And all this, you know, pours into
my -- to me, into becoming a poet.
You know, the inspiration of my
mother, the hard stories of women
in the '30s that were kept back, and
how they tore away and broke away
and joined the radio shows like
Cuka, like Ave, like Elvira,
and became great singers and
became great songwriters,
and became great dancers,
and travelled throughout
Texas with chaperones.
[ Laughter ]
So this is Cuka and Ava
and Elvira as teenagers.
And they were famous all
over El Paso, all over Texas,
and their only album was locked
up in a vault and never released.
So that's why I want
you to meet them,
because let us release their story.
You want to do that?
>> Yes.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Let us release their story.
[ Applause ]
And Cuka, the one on the left,
bottom left, still living.
And like I said, she's
in her late 90s.
She's in her late --
she's always having jokes,
you know, joking around.
"Oh, you haven't called me
in a long time, Juanito.
It's about time, Juanito.
You big laureate, you."
[ Laughter ]
What could I do?
It was a -- I said,
"Yes, yes, dear Cuka."
I call her Aunt Cuka.
"Yes, Aunt Cuka.
How are you doing?"
And then we have a conversation.
And my uncle was part
of the same group.
And in those days poets
and singers could publish
in a small little insert in a
newspaper of [foreign words],
The Continental Newspaper of
Juarez , which we talked about,
where Poncho Villa crossed through
and Anthony Quinn and my mother
and family stayed for a while.
So there you see, here you
see my uncle performing
with Cuka when she's 16.
And you see my uncle looking
really flashy up there,
Roberto Quintana, who was a poet.
Yeah. I didn't know that until
I found this piece of paper
in Cuka's archives which
burnt down a few weeks ago.
Her house burnt down to a crisp,
and all her archives and photos
and everything, songs,
went up in smoke.
So that's why we're
celebrating her again tonight.
Yes, indeed.
[ Applause ]
So here's a little bit
of my uncle's poem,
which was one of the few poems we
find from the '30s of Mexicanos
on the border of Juarez and El Paso.
It's, I think that's the only poem
that we have available of that era
in this group of artists.
And he used this voice of
a working-class worker,
a working-class kind of a person
that was moved and pushed around
and directed by the big
patron, the big patron.
So in -- the big boss.
So in this poem he writes in the
voice of the man from the pueblo,
the worker, pueblo worker,
regarding el patron.
I want to read a part of it
to just give you an idea,
a little bit in Spanish,
a little bit in English.
And I'm going to use that voice.
It's called [foreign words],
"Street Conversations,"
which is a cool title.
As a matter of fact, Split Rock, I
want you to use that title, okay,
and create a nice little
rap out of it, okay?
"Street Conversations."
This is told by the voice
of Pablo Ranchero, Pablo,
the rancher, the rancherman.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
"I'm telling you that in those
days el patron [foreign words],
the boss used to look after me.
[Foreign words], and
kind of liked me.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
On Sundays he would give
me a little bit of corn.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And other times he gave me
my, my little bit of money.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
He would invite me
to eat in his house,
his house [laughter], his house.
[ Laughter ]
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And then he would tell
me to go to the kitchen.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Well they were going to give me
big deep bowls and a lot to eat."
And then the poem continues.
And it gets, it gets deeper and it
gets very heartfelt as it moves on.
And that's the poem -- and
those are some of the voices
of our early poets in the '30s on
the borderland of Juarez, El Paso,
that we have today right
here for the first time.
No one has seen this.
No one has heard this.
And I'm so happy that you
can hear it and see it,
at least for a little while.
"Pioneers of Flower and
Song [foreign words]",
poetry in its many forms.
And perhaps in a way that
we have not been exposed to.
And that's what we do.
That's what we do here at
the Library of Congress.
But this kept on, you know,
this further revolution,
the spirit of the working
class, the spirit of bringing
out what's taking place in Mexico.
It was taken up by the great
painters, that later were taken
up by the poets, the ones
we're going to talk about.
So here are some images of those
early '30s exuberant responses
and feverish responses and
full all-out painted responses,
in big walls, not little
walls, big walls,
by the great muralists Jose Clemente
Orozco, Diego Rivera, as you know,
and David Alfaro Sequeiros.
And these particular murals were
very inspiring decades later.
That great new democracy of the '60s
that we all wanted to
be part of, you know?
Inspired by many -- Martin
Luther King, Dolores Huerta,
the gay movement, the workers'
movement, the student movement,
and just the desire to
bring equality for all.
And the next piece, you know, we
have one of our poets, Jose Montoya,
that passed away also last year.
And you see him with his interesting
outfit because he belonged
and founded the Royal
Chicano Air Force --
[ Laughter ]
-- which was a mural
squad, a mural squadron
that went throughout the
Southwest painting murals.
So that's the Royal
Chicano Air Force.
And he, you know, you have to
-- if you're in the Air Force,
you got to dress like
you're in the Air Force.
And behind him you see the
Farm Workers' flag, the eagle,
which he was part of, the Aztec
eagle, which he was part of,
that is, the Farm Workers Movement.
It all blends in.
All these things blend
in and become one.
The indigenous origins of the
first peoples of this hemisphere,
their texts that have been
translated into English,
and then were translated into -- I
mean to Spanish and then English,
and the poetic eye and the poetic
imagination of our new generations,
in the '60s in this case, where many
of my friends and I
came to be poets.
And that's Jose Montoya, the great
poet, the great muralist, who,
once again, is not known at large.
And yet if you go to
Latino, Mexicano, Chicano,
Chicano communities and
you say Jose Montoya,
they go, yeah, Jose Montoya.
So we're saying yeah, yeah,
Jose Montoya here today, too.
[ Applause ]
Let's see what that land looked like
when I was a kid, as me and my mom
and my father's colossal
army truck [laughter].
Looks like he actually
built that, tool,
that he got in El Paso
at Fort Bliss.
And there's my mom
and -- holding me.
I'm looking philosophically
at the camera.
And there's me again after planting
corn with my father in a little lot
in Escondido owned
by La Familia Garcia.
And I'm kind of upset
there because there's a lot
of spiders in the cornfields.
And if you're just running
through the cornfields,
you're going to find a spider
right here stuck to your cheek,
and you say, hello,
spider [laughter].
I'd like to move on, okay?
[ Laughter ]
So that's me there,
and that's how I began.
My mother, the storyteller
out in the open.
And the cornfield.
And that world at the
margin of the big city.
Speaking Spanish only.
And hearing the great
stories of my parents.
My father, who had many stories.
And my mother who was a
storyteller and poet who liked
to stand up unexpectedly.
And then school days.
First grade.
I had a hard time in first grade --
-- only knowing Spanish.
I didn't know what a school was
or a door was or a classroom was.
And being punished for speaking
Spanish the first 10 seconds
of class was a hard way to start.
Though my teachers also saved
me a couple of years later.
You know Mrs. Sampson,
remember Mrs. Sampson.
>> Yes.
>> Jose Felipe Herrera: Yes.
My third grade teacher who said,
"You have a beautiful voice."
And that took care of it.
And that's what I'm
saying to you today, too.
I'm still saying that
because she said that.
You have a beautiful voice.
And we say that here at the
Library of Congress because full
of beautiful voices and
you have a beautiful voice.
Alurista.
>> Woo.
[ Laughter ]
He's from Acapulco.
He was from -- he's from Acapulco.
He's one of my -- we
met in middle school.
Came over to my little apartment my
father had found downtown San Diego
on Broadway, 11th and D Street,
next to Broadway, San Diego.
And someone knocked on my
door, my one-room apartment,
our one-room apartment, and he said,
-- I opened the door [inaudible].
He says, [foreign words]
do you have any paper?
I go, "paper?
Of course I got paper.
School just started."
You know, you get those 500 pounds
of paper [laughter]
and a big old binder.
"Of course."
"Okay, can I borrow some?"
And now freeze that frame
because what happened was
that he became a pioneer
in Chicano poetry
that influenced thousands a few
years later after high school.
But that's how we met each other,
asking each other, asking for paper
and giving each other paper,
and taking him to school,
and hanging out, and talking about
many things, including Aztec history
and language and symbols.
As a matter of fact, he brought out
a great Aztec term called Aztlan,
the land of the North Country, the
Aztec land of the North Country,
the origin of migration
south to Mexico City.
And he said, "You know
what that is?"
I go, "Wow, what is that?
I'm doing my homework.
What is it.
What are you talking about?"
"Aztlan." I go, "Okay,
Aztlan, and, and, and?"
"It's the Southwest, Juan.
It's the Southwest."
"Okay. How come it's
not on the map?"
[ Laughter ]
He says, "Oh, come
on, Juan," he says.
"We have to rewrite the map.
That's what poets do."
I go, "Oh, a poet, huh?
Okay. Okay.
I got some poems.
You want to listen to them?"
[ Laughter ]
He was a little bit ahead of me.
So that's Alurista, you
know, a great pioneer
with a great book called
Floricanto ,
[inaudible] 1971, [foreign words].
So now you see that big arc
from 300/400 B.C. to 1971.
This is one of his poems
called "We Played Cowboys."
"We played cowboys, not knowing
[foreign words], our singers,
and their continents [foreign
words], this beautiful regalia,
silver embroidery on black
wool, Zapata wrote in white,
campesina white and Villa in
brown [foreign words] parade
of sculptured gods on
horses of flowing manes,
proud, erect, they galloped.
And we played cowboys
as opposed to Indians
when ancestors [foreign words]
of my grandparents, charros,
Indians, [foreign words].
They were [foreign words] of
that central area of Mexico
and of the humid jungles of Yucatan.
[Foreign words], our Mayas if we
must, cowboys play [foreign words]
with moustaches [foreign words]."
[ Applause ]
So I would listen to him
breathe and speak and recite.
I go, charros, cowboys,
[foreign words].
That's English.
That's Spanish.
That sounds good.
Wow. Pyramids.
Indio's, Mayas, jungles.
Oh, I was taking notes [laughter].
So, you know, society
was our workshop.
It is always our workshop,
whether we write alone
or whether we write out in the open.
It is not possible without
social combustion, social change,
and social human beings with
voices and hearts and struggles
and conflicts and happiness
and joy and riding
on horses in full regalia.
Jose Antonio Burciaga also
passed away, a great writer.
He was a muralist, too.
And he painted murals at Stanford
and he wrote amazing columns
about Mexican Chicano culture.
He has a book called Drink
Cultura , Drink Cultura ,
and it's hilarious, and it's deep,
and it's piercing, and it's funny,
and it's informative,
and you can serve it
like hot butter on a tortilla.
>> Yeah [laughter].
>> Jose Felipe Herrera: But you're
going to taste that salt, too.
You're going to taste that salt,
too, and that chilito, too.
A great writer, a great muralist,
and a keen mind who passed away.
And let us remember him as well.
One of my cohorts and a great
mentor, Jose Antonio Burciaga.
And there I'm attempting to
look really cool [laughter].
So I want you to remember
Jose and look up his murals
and see what you think about his
books and his poems and stories.
Let us accept all our stories and
all our images and all our dreams.
Gloria Anzaldua is
another great pioneer.
Lesbian, Chicana [foreign word],
Mexican, American, [foreign word].
She doesn't like one designation.
She opposed one designation.
She said, "I'm not one thing.
I'm a person filled
with explosive borders.
I am the borderlands.
And there's a wound," she says.
And everybody goes,
"What [laughter]?"
And she says, "There is a state
that we can go into, that's a state
of Coatlicue, the Coatlicue.
You mean the Goddess of the Aztecs?
You mean the goddess that wears
serpent skirts and death skulls
as belts, and has claw feet,
and stands very, very tall,
made out of stone, Coatlicue?
A state of Coatlicue?
What on Earth is that?
But she was reshaping
and reinvestigating
that Nahuatl Mashika ancient culture
which had not been
interpreted by women.
And her book, Mestiza Borderlands
is a great change-maker,
a great game-changer --
-- as you'll see in the mid-'80s.
This is a piece called [foreign
word] by Gloria Anzaldua.
"Driving down the canyon on
a road gouged out of the side
of a mountain, red, red earth,
and exposed roots sticking
out like amputated
fingers, 145 acres for sale,
the Indians safely locked up in
reservations or urban ghettos.
Driving around the mountain inside
the car, fighting for silence.
Houses stick out like pimples
on the face of the mountain.
At the skirt of the
mountain ranges I met a woman
from a nearby extinct
tribe, the [foreign word].
Her name was [foreign
word], meaning road runner.
By a stream amidst the gushing
water under the olive wooly head
of the mountain I met her.
Under the Encina Tree I sat.
She emerged out of the smooth amber
flesh of the manzanita in sandals
of woven yucca, skin
polished bronze by the sun.
She appeared with a tattoo on her
arm, pricked by cactus thorns,
ground charcoal rubbed on the wound.
There's a forest fire
on the Cuyamaca Peaks,
a sign, four parcels for sale.
The Indians locked
up in reservations [foreign words]
behind glass in the museum."
Gloria Anzaldua, great pioneer,
also passed away a few years ago.
So I'm glad we have a chance to say
hi and to meet them and see them
and hear a few of their
works and notice
that they were great
pioneers, speaking at a time
when it was difficult to speak.
Many forces working against us
and them, and yet they continued
and forged ahead, and became
game-changers with words,
with beautiful poetry,
with art and stories
and a deep compassionate heart.
Ray Gonzalez is also from El Paso
and he knows all about Juarez.
And he's a great collector
of poems and a great person
that puts a lot of
anthologies together.
I tell Ray, "You saved
me in the '90s, Ray.
I was going down.
I wasn't publishing anything.
Thank you."
You know, our good friends who
are editors and our good friends
who are critics of
literature, and they love it.
And they look out for us writers,
and they go, "I want
a poem from you.
I'm putting together a book."
And we are not -- we cannot
be poets without our editors,
without our thinkers, without
our people that put many hours
into collecting those
poems and creating a book.
But we have a little press of
time because with our poem.
Ray Gonzalez.
He has many books, one recently
published in Belgium, a Chatbook.
I'm looking for at this point
who is also a great poet.
And she decided to just come
on all the way out and talk
about being a Superwoman Chicana.
She didn't hold back [laughter].
She didn't hold back.
I don't think any male ever said I'm
a super, super, Superman Chicano.
I don't think there's
any such thing.
So it just came straight on out.
And it was a very fun
book, a very good book,
and Gloria Velasquez
an excellent poet.
I want to read you part
of one of her poems called
"Days Gone by in Orange County."
"I mourn for those days gone by,
the slim-waisted girl I once was,
dressed in beads, the
bearded Chicano
at my side screaming obscenities
at the crowds, waving Peace signs,
drinking beer in honky-tonk
bars, with cowboy and his dogs,
and the Beatles, and the
smell of stale muscatel.
I mourn for those days gone by.
Martin Luther King, Junior.
Nigger-lovers they shouted at us.
[Inaudible] and food-stamps,
Vietnam pouring out of the cracks,
the smell of Fenni's
[assumed spelling] burnt skin,
the closed coffin, and
my mother's screams.
I curse those days gone by
sitting here in my office,
surrounded by mediocrity, academic
pimps, Martin Luther Kind dead
on the wall, letters from Vietnam
neatly stacked on the shelf.
No more stale muscatel.
No more bearded Chicano.
No more days gone by."
[ Applause ]
I want you to meet Victor Martinez,
another pioneer of
"Flower and Song."
If there was ever a
thinker, it was Victor.
If there ever was a deep
If there ever was someone who
could write forever and never go
out of the house or the
room, it was Victor.
I used to say, "Victor,
I just turned out a poem.
How about you?
What do you got?"
"Uh, I'm editing my poem poem."
"But what do you got?"
"I got two pages."
"Two pages?
I sent out like 400 pages
yesterday [laughter]."
"I'm working on the
lines [laughter].
I need to polish my lines."
"Come on, Victor.
Just send it out."
"I'm looking at the terms, Juan.
It's important.
Okay?
[ Laughter ]
I don't know about you, but
I want to take my time."
[ Laughter ]
And sure enough, I had a
billion typos in those poems
that I published [laughter].
And guess what.
Victor won the National
Book Award --
>> Yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
-- in 1996 --
[ Applause ]
-- for A Parrot in the
Oven , a young adult novel,
and a hard-hitting young adult
novel, A Parrot in the Oven .
So I want you to meet
Victor for a moment.
He also passed away, a young man.
It's called "Along the River" from
his book, Caring for a House ,
published by Chusma Press
in San Jose in the mid-'80s.
"Along the River."
"There are sunrises where
everything that pains us leaves,
where one's arm twisted on a
question, unravels its answer,
and the fraction of a face becomes
whole, that some blossom shards
of glass, opposites everywhere.
Yet none of them touches us.
We're in a forest gummed
together by light,
beside a river whose
currents are feathers,
twittering to become wind
before the sun shreds them madly
to their source.
And after the seedless sowing
of late afternoon shadows,
when the forest moves at
the speed the sun pulls,
we say this is what I am.
A sky frightened, a sky
of frightened birds,
an unmapped constellation
of pores, morning
and night forever stroking
the wheel with each hand.
Sun, moon, all the rest."
[ Applause ]
Lucha Corpi is also a great pioneer,
a founder of the Centralist [foreign
word] Chicanos in the Bay Area,
the Francisco [foreign word].
Lucha Corpi from Vera Cruz,
the Atlantic coast of Mexico.
And very interested in translating
her work in Spanish into English
and working with a
translator, and her own poetry.
"In the opening and shutting
of an eye full of magic clocks
and old dreams, winter comes.
The wind murmurs melancholy as the
all's well of the night watchman
who looked after my parents' house.
I go back every winter lest I forget
who I am and where I come from.
The rain comes down singing towards
its destiny of mineral and seed.
Between the hollow of an opening
wing and the lowering of violets
in repose, we learn
to love, in instants
and surrenders in-between the
intimate question posed by night
and the dark sweet
reply given by dawn.
We engender in pain a new life.
Nothing is fixed or
perpetual, not rain or seed
or you or I or our grief.
In this world that is fleeting
because we're forever cutting paths,
opening our way along unfamiliar
roads, conquering the fury
of oblivion verse by verse."
"Winter Song" by Lucha Corpi.
[ Applause ]
And let's go back to
Francisco Alarcon.
[ Applause ]
He just lived life.
He lived life.
"Juan Felipe."
"Yes." "Let's go have some dinner."
"But it's 11:30."
"Let's go [laughter]."
"Where we going?"
"Guadalajara de Noche,"
a great Mexican restaurant
in the Mission District.
I said, "Okay.
And what are we going to do."
"We're going to talk poetry, Juan.
What else is there?"
>> Yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
He was a great scholar.
Like I said, a great pioneer of
Nahuatl text in a whole new format
and idiom that no one
has really written about.
So I'm presenting to you a pioneer
that has not really been examined,
given his writing corpus,
what he's really provided
that no one else has provided.
"Flower and Song" pioneer.
This is called "Mestizo."
"My name is not Francisco.
There is an Arab within me who
prays three times each day.
Behind my Roman nose there
is a Phoenician smiling.
My eyes still see Seville,
but my mouth is [inaudible].
My dark hands are Toltec.
My cheek bones fierce Chichimeca.
My feet recognize no border,
no rule, no code, no lord,
for this wanderer's heart,
for this wanderer's heart."
[ Applause ]
Let me present to you Gary Soto.
You know Gary.
He has many, many, many
books for children,
almost in every school
in the nation.
A great writer.
Also from Fresno, the
capital of poetry.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Fresno is
everywhere [laughter].
>> Yes.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
And in the mid-'70s
around the same time Carolyn Forche
put out Gathering the Tribes ,
it was kind of a pivotal
year in some wild way.
Carolyn Forche's book, wild
and tense, terse, short lines,
incredible, that could cut
you down in 10 seconds flat.
I love that book, Gathering
the Tribes .
And Gary Soto, all of a
sudden is writing in English.
The Aztecs are in there somewhere
but they're not in the same manner.
And it's not bilingual.
And it's in English.
And it feels good.
All of a sudden it feels good.
And Gary presents that new
interesting redirection as well
as everything else
that was taking place.
This is called "Field" from
the Elements of San Joaquin .
"The wind sprays pale
dirt into my mouth.
The small, almost invisible scars
on my hands, the pores in my throat
and elbows have taken in a
seed of dirt of their own.
After a day in the grape fields
near Rolinda, I'll find silt washed
by sweat has settled into the
lines on the wrists and palms.
Already I'm becoming the valley,
a soil that sprouts
nothing for any of us."
[ Applause ]
Everybody reads Gary Soto.
Whenever I meet young
people, "I like Gary Soto.
I love Gary Soto, Juan.
I love Gary."
I said, "I'm glad you love Gary.
I'm glad you love Gary.
That's good.
That's good, you know.
Reading those great books, young
adult books and poetry books."
Raul Salinas, Raul Salinas.
And here you see -- this is 1973
at USC, November 13th and 14th
when we had the first
Chicano Literature conference
that where we came together
for the first time ever at USC.
And at USC [laughter].
It was one of Alurista's ideas, too,
because it was called
[foreign words].
Once again, "Flower and
Song," [foreign words].
This keeps on coming
up and continues.
It doesn't really ends.
And, of course, here we have
our great pioneers, too.
[Inaudible], great scholar
in literature on the right,
and Rolando [foreign
words] Smith as well,
and [foreign words] a great poet
and educator and also storywriter,
fiction writer, a innovative
pioneering trio that moved us,
very much so, and inspired us, 1973.
And also in 1973, in the same
conference, we have Raul Salinas.
What a guy.
Raul Salinas, with a swagger
and a hit band and tattoos
and the big deep baritone
voice, and great poems that kind
of astonished us, that
we couldn't believe it.
And he said something like
this at the conference,
like in this mode that you see here.
And, of course, you
know, he came from the --
from like the barrios where we
all came from, and from Texas,
and he had served a number of years
in Leavenworth for minor infractions
that just kept on piling up.
And they just kept on piling up.
And he was out.
He was fresh out, feeling great.
And he had a poem called,
a poem, a very popular,
a famous poem where he talks about
being a pachuco, being a, you know,
a borderlands youth with a swagger
and a whole new style
called a pachuco.
Early days, in the '30s,
back in Cuka's days
where the pachuco was born
in Juarez and El Paso.
And that's a whole other story.
He said, that's a loco dig on what?
What them dudes are saying
that you write [foreign word],
a non-goal-oriented being
who fear an identity crisis.
[Foreign word] This guy, he's
[inaudible] and you boogied
into [inaudible] and to U.S.
naval battlegrounds, room one.
The pachuco's a pachuco.
Room two. Everything you ever wanted
to know about a pachuco, room three,
the post-modern view of pachuconess.
[ Laughter ]
Everybody going, what did he say?
Pachuco? Room one?
That just sprang --
He had a whole thing
about what anthropologists
were saying at that time
about young Mexican Chicanos in
barrios, that they were alienated,
that they were non-goal-oriented.
So he decided to respond with his
poetry in this particular poem, oh,
you loco dig on what
them dudes are saying
that you are non-goal-oriented
being, so feel an identity crisis.
[ Laughter ]
And with that big booming voice
and his great tasty style,
we were really moved.
And he also passed away.
One of our great pioneers
and bilingual, indigenous.
He spent many years in the
Indian Movement and a true --
a true seeker and partner of
Indian Nations, United States.
And his poetry came out of that,
so he kind of encompassed the
entire sphere of the Chicano,
Mexican experience in the
United States from all levels.
And I'm so honored to have
known him Raul Salinas.
His latest book -- his last book
was called Indio Trails which is a
beautiful, beautiful collection.
Let us go back to Jose Montoya
just a little bit as we begin
to close the pioneer, flote cato,
pioneers, flour and salt pioneers.
Jose Montoya, we saw a little
bit of his artwork earlier on.
Jose Montoya was in the Korean
-- served in the Korean War.
Jose Montoya was from
Fowler, where I was born.
Jose Montoya worked in the
fields, his whole family worked
in the fields, and as you know,
Jose Montoya was a great muralist.
I'd like you to explore his
murals, art, music, song,
painting, poetry, community.
This is a song, this is from --
I'm going to read a little bit
of the poem that he wrote for,
called "La Jefita," La Jefita, our
dear mothers, Mi Jefita, my mother.
Mi Jefito, my father, and of course,
this is our terms that we use
of endearment, of endearment.
And he describes that
his mom in the morning.
"A noisy chorro spill,
missing the basin.
Que horas son, ama?
What time is it, mom?
Es tarde, me hijito.
It's late.
Cover up your little brothers.
Y yo con pena, but too
sleepy and I felt kind
of ashamed, but too sleepy.
Get to bed little mother.
A maternal reply mingled
with the hissing
of the hot planchas,
those hot ironing irons.
Y los frijoles de la hoya and
the frijoles steaming up on
that big kettle, boiling musically.
Danto segunda, give
it a second tone.
A los ruidos nocturnos, the
night sounds and the snores
of the old man, lulling
sounds, e los peros,
and the dogs, ladrando, barking.
Then the familiar hallucinations
just before sleep.
And my jefita, no more.
But then it was time to get up.
My old man had a chiflidito, a
little whistle [whistling sounds].
That irritated the
world to wakefulness.
[Whistling sounds] Ariba
cabrones chavalos, get up there.
What's the matter with
you [laughter]?